Hello!
I am David Kaplan and I am not an expert,
but I hope in this series to learn as much
as possible and explain it to you the best
way I can.
Imagine being in the desert, a desert which
is very uniform.
You look in any direction, you see the same
thing.
That, seeing the same thing, means there’s
a symmetry in that state.
It’s a rotational symmetry.
Now take the desert and add roads and casinos,
lots of stuff.
Now every direction you look it looks completely
different, so that is a situation where an
underlying symmetry exists but the state of
the system breaks it.
This is something that occurs with the laws
of nature.
It is these broken symmetries — the underlying,
hidden symmetries in the laws — that allow
us to discover deeper and deeper aspects of
forces and particles.
The Higgs boson is a great example of that.
The Higgs boson was predicted as something
that breaks a symmetry of the theory of fundamental
particles, called the standard model.
The symmetry that was broken has effects like
making the electron and the neutrino completely
different.
The electron is a particle that lives in the
atom.
It has electric charge.
It’s very important for all of matter.
And the neutrino moves through space near
the speed of light, fills the universe but
otherwise doesn’t seem very important.
How could these two particles have been roughly
the same particle in the early universe?
That’s because, we’ve discovered, there’s
a symmetry that connects them.
And at some point, as the temperature of the
universe cooled, that symmetry broke and the
breaking was due to the Higgs mechanism.
And the theory that predicted that breaking
also predicted the particle that was just
discovered a few years ago.
So the insights — which are “What are
the symmetries that guide and structure the
fundamental laws?”
— lead to discoveries like the Higgs and
a deeper understanding about how all particles
and forces work.